hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
Captain Marvel has been out for almost a
week now and with its release people
have been asking how exactly did shield
get the tesseract if you are worried
about any spoilers for Captain Marvel
don't worry there won't be any in this
video you should already know that
shield ultimately gets their hands on
the tesseract by the two films Captain
America the First Avenger and the
original Avengers movie so in this video
I'll explain how shield got it how it
landed in project Pegasus and also
explained the entire timeline of the
tesseract and before we get started a
quick reminder about my giveaway giving
away five imax tickets if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is to be subscribed to my
channel like the video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so the
start of the tesseract and the MCU
actually starts with Odin Odin acquires
the tesseract in the past and brings it
to earth Odin would ultimately leave it
on earth and it would be kept in Toms
burg Norway it was guarded by Walter
flinch but he couldn't stop Red Skull
from getting it Red Skull would have the
tesseract throughout the events of
Captain America the First Avenger until
the end where it eventually teleports
him to Boromir and then sinks to the
bottom of the ocean it is eventually
recovered by Howard Stark and this is
how it gets into the hands of shield
because Howard Stark is one of the
founders of shield and then project
Pegasus was born which was a joint
venture between shield and NASA project
Pegasus was created for the purpose of
analyzing the tesseract
the tesseract would remain with shield
and project Pegasus until the events of
the first Avengers movie where Loki
takes it ultimately the Avengers end up
defeating Loki and at the end of the
movie Thor takes the tesseract along
with Loki back to Asgard where the
tesseract would remain in Odin's vault
the tesseract would remain in Odin's
vault for a very long time up until the
end of Thor Ragnarok where Loki takes it
again
[Music]
this time Loki would only have the
tesseract for a very short period of
time because shortly after thinner shows
up and forces Loki to give him the
tesseract in order to save Thor's life
Loki gives the tesseract to Thanos in
which Thanos crushes the tesseract grabs
the space stone from inside of it and
puts it inside of the Infinity Gauntlet
and that is where it currently remains
so that is the timeline of the tesseract
/ space stone in the MCU shield had the
tesseract for a very long time and
throughout that time it was studied by
many scientists including Howard Stark
dr. Lawson and dr. Erik Selvig and again
project Pegasus was a joint venture
between shield and NASA founded for the
sole purpose of study in the tesseract
so for those of you who have seen
Captain Marvel and have been asking many
questions about it I hope this clears a
few things up and answer some of your
questions but be sure to leave your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel Avengers
in-game and Captain Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you